[Music]
on today's show we talk about losing
your faith and how to talk to your
parents
we talk about mental health challenges
when you're married to somebody who's
struggling
and we talk about extended grief after
the passing of somebody's mom
and several of these calls have some
major plot twists
stay tuned
[Music]
hey what up this is john with the dr
john dalone show
man it's good to see you and i can't
even see you so it's good to
hear i can't even hear you it's good to
be with you
and going through all my automated
responses here hey this is a show about
mental health about wellness about
relationships relational iq
about trying to do the next smart good
best thing that you can
how to deal with your parents how to
deal with your kids all of it talking
about your life
it's a call for you and about you real
calls from real people
if you want to be on this show if you
want to be on the show give me a call at
1-844-693-3291 that's
you can go to 1-844-693-3291 ask
ask john doloney.com ask
all right so hey james i had a
for those who don't know knew the show
james is the producer of the show he
sits behind the looking glass alice in
wonderland style
listen i know both you and me are
have different parenting than some of
our other friends
so i live by the old homer simpson
quote which is one of the coolest things
about having kids is to teach them to
hate the things that you hate i think
that's just fun
unless it's like other people then it's
ridiculous and evil but
since my son was little every time we
would drive by and see the golden arches
of mcdonald's i would just tell them
like
oh that's disgusting oh and we all would
boo it
and then his sister came along and now
they just do it no matter what i could
be
not even paying attention driving down
the road rolling rolling rolling like
limb biscuit and then all sudden i hear
this
and i'll just stop like what's going on
so
i thought that was part of our funny
family lore
and then my son comes home the other
night he's 11 now
he's hanging out with his friends they
went to like a minor league baseball
game or something
some dad took him some awesome parent
says hey i'm going to take a bunch of 10
year olds and 11 year olds to
a game that's a saint they don't like
that
they don't even have to go to church
they're just in so
my son comes home like hey what'd y'all
do how was it and he said it was great
fun i said what's you for dinner he said
well i just
had a couple of french fries i said why
i gave you some money and he goes well
they all went
they'd drive throw through mcdonald's
and i said well did you eat
and he goes no i told him i just didn't
want to support that
i that's amazing no
i see you laughing back there because
you understand part of me was so proud
like you're exactly right i don't
support it and part of me was like dude
eat a cheeseburger man
with your friends be a human being if
you
he's like i don't want to partake like
it's cocaine like hey it was like hey
dad
listen we were all hanging out and it
was just a few beers and then
billy whipped out the heroine and i was
like hey
i remember what nancy reagan said just
say no and so he just said no
my kids uh we were at this church
meeting yesterday and they had soda
there for lunch it was like they had
lunch provided
and we just don't really drink soda like
they like lacroix
and they kind of think that lacroix is
soda
and so they thought that like soda was
like
had alcohol in it or something like the
kids couldn't drink it we didn't we
never told them that but they just got
in their minds like soda was not for
kids so they would see kids at school
and be like oh my gosh
so we're like guys you can have like we
need to let them have some soda so they
can know what it's all about so they had
some dr pepper today and they realized
it was the best thing ever and so
so here's what's gonna happen our kids
your mind they're gonna get to college
and their friends are gonna be like hey
listen let's do a whole bunch of shrooms
and they're gonna first think we
shouldn't do that and then they're gonna
remember
my parents told me that uh mcdonald's
was the scourge of the earth and
dr pepper would kill me and those ended
up being incredible or their
rebellion will be going to mcdonald's
and just getting like
a super size with the coke and that'll
be their
they're not going to do shrooms they're
going to go to sonic this
we're geniuses kelly do your kids go to
mcdonald's
no actually when donald we don't i can't
tell you the last time we've been to
mcdonald's and
my son has always been that he's like he
saw the pink slime video years ago
oh yeah and so he's like i'm not eating
that but i mean he'll knock out a
hamburger like nobody's business but he
just gets it yeah we're just not
mcdonald's
with two but me and my son can punish
some taco bell all right so
let's go to the phones let's talk to
michael in dayton ohio what's up michael
what's going on man
hi john how are you i'm outstanding
brother how are you
doing well good mama taught me that you
couldn't have kept until you're 18. so
awesome man so what's up um so i was
calling so a little background i grew up
in a evangelical christian family
and grew up in distance from that and
now
i have a girlfriend who's jewish and
just difficulties of explaining that to
my parents and
navigating that so you say like so
you're not you're not
practicing christian anymore not
particularly
okay cool so then you met somebody who's
jewish and have you talked to your
parents about it have you not told them
what's the deal with that
so i have mentioned that but i haven't
really told my parents that
i'm not practicing religiously i just
kind of always felt like i could at
least performatively
maintain a religion just to uh maintain
peace in the household
so um how's that working out for you
um definitely causes a little bit of uh
tension for myself yeah i do the more
you have to perform or be dishonest
or lie to your parents in order to keep
the peace
the more that will leak out in other
areas and counseling we used to call it
um
leakage which is sounds like it's a
dirty diaper it kind of is actually
but it will find its way out it just
usually comes out in real inopportune
times
right it'll come up in some huge blowout
or they'll find out and then suddenly
they'll realize you lied to them for ten
years
and partridge in a pear tree right so
um when you say like they kind of know
what does that mean
so i have mentioned to parents that
she's jewish and um that matters to her
and i've just kept on
mom's thought that oh you know she'll
become a christian too
eventually and it'll work itself out
that way
i think the way i could phrase it
so how can i help what are you asking me
um i think for me the um
challenge is how to approach this
while maintaining a relationship with my
parents and also
to this happened a long time before i
met my
girlfriend i don't want my parents
disliking her
and seeing her as the reason why
what happened that's exactly dude you're
a wise man so
um the longer you put off this
conversation the more
their existential angst of your
um choice of religious practice or
non-religious practice
will be dumped on her
and so i i is this somebody you're going
to marry you can spend your time with
her
you like this girl absolutely okay
that's awesome
so here's here's what you got to do man
i don't see a way around it
and how old are you i'm uh 27 right now
yeah i think it's a i know people in
their 40s i know someone who's almost 50
who will say things like hey like hey
don't tell my parents but
and i'm thinking dude you're 40 what are
you like what are they gonna do
you know they're gonna grab like what
kind of weird stuff is going so
you're 27 man you're a professional
you're grown up you're about to get you
know married
i think it's time to take them out
right you're carrying a bag of bricks
here every time you're with them you're
not able to fully be yourself
and i do think there's a before i tell
you what i think like what i would do if
i'm in your situation what i have done
if i'm
in in your situation just with different
things
is this there's a difference between
being authentic
and not being dishonest and then there's
a
but you can do that and then there's
just being an idiot being a jerk
right so the difference of being sitting
down and saying hey listen
um i love you guys
i want y'all to know that i'm so
grateful for the house i grew up and i'm
so grateful for you too
i know and honor your christian faith
i haven't been there for years and
it's not anything you all did you didn't
screw anything up
where i am right now in my life that's
not a part of my life
and i want you to know i still carry
with me the lessons of character i still
carry the lessons
of how to treat people right with
dignity and all those things that they
taught you right
um and i want you to expect them
to be heartbroken about that if they
truly have a religious belief that they
are
are staked in the ground as is the
truth and the right way and partridge
into pear tree
um they they should be disappointed
right they should be heartbroken about
that
and let them know i want to keep our
relationship strong
i want to continue to be here and then
this is where the respect part comes in
that's when you don't bad mouth them for
going to church
that's when they if your mom says hey
when you're when you come visit us
we'd like you to come with us that you
can go right
if it becomes offensive and
heartbreaking then that's a whole other
conversation but
does that make sense there's a balance
between being honest and being an idiot
absolutely i've like i i still in a way
see religious good just not some of the
exclusivity parts
okay so that's question that's
conversation number one
and i think you have it at the same time
the next part of that
is i really love this girl
the jewish faith is a big part of her
life
i want you to know that she's gonna be a
part of my life i hope so much she can
be a part of y'all's life too
i want i have these pictures in my head
of
our christmases and our um teaching
teaching you guys what hanukkah looks
like i've got these pictures of what
thanksgiving
oh all the different you know whatever's
i'm just making up as we go here
but um i want you all to know the
expectation won't be that
i'm gonna turn her into something that
she's not
and i hope that you guys will still love
her just like you would
my any other wife that i brought home um
and then here's where it's hard for you
brother they get to choose what they do
next
they do they get to choose and they can
say
then we disown you we hate you you're
not our son anymore i don't think that's
going to happen
that happens all over the world by the
way but i don't think that's going to
happen with you
they are going to have a season of
mourning they may want to take you out
again and talk to you about it they may
send you books and tracks and
all of that is them trying to do the
best they can to love you in the ways
that they know how
right and so if you can
it may be annoying it may be frustrating
maybe whatever but it's him just trying
to love you
and if you can honor them by letting
them love you even if it's
in weird ways then so be it um but they
get to decide what they do next and
that's the hard part of any sort of
relational
truth-telling right it is
you seem nervous that you're going to
lose them do you think they're going to
bail on you
i i don't think so it's just i know that
i'm going to be the different one from
the rest of my family
and you've always been a different one
michael
haven't you yes i have
yeah see it's nothing new you're just
calling it out
that is true i think sometimes it's just
i think you have this conversation
sooner rather than later um you're gonna
it won't
feel good but you will be lighter you'll
move through the world
lighter you'll be able to look your mom
and your dad in the eyes and know that
they're telling the truth
and if you do this in a respectful
dignified and honorable way
and not choose to go to war because
you're uncomfortable
um man that's that's the best way to
treat people with dignity
i love you and i care about you and i've
come to some different conclusions in my
life
and i'm going to continue to love you
and honor you and be respectful
and i'm asking you guys to give me that
same honor and respect and dignity back
right and by the way you're about to get
a new daughter-in-law and i hope you
will love her and
be hospitable to her and invite her in
your home and learn and ask
questions and and tell her tell your
your soon-to-be fiance soon to be wife
hey man we're just gonna
we're gonna teach we're gonna love we're
gonna learn my parents are gonna stumble
through this for a while
and we're all gonna be on the same team
my brothers and sisters are gonna
stumble through this and figure it out
but we're all gonna be doing this
together right that's how
messy family disagreements
plus different beliefs plus all the
stuff
can end around end up sitting around a
table all eating
all sharing all still loving loving each
other
even though we end up on same on
different sides of issues
right religion's a tough one man but
michael be honest be truthful be
yourself and be respectful brother
that's the best you can do right now all
right hey thank you so much for your
call hey stay tuned we'll be right back
with the dr john delaney show
the world has become more and more
chaotic and uncertain
and loud and it seems that everyone has
anxiety
i've been there and so have you it's why
i wrote this small
direct and personal book called
redefining anxiety
in this book i discussed what anxiety is
what it's not
and how you can get back on the road of
being whole and well
listen you are not broken and i'm living
proof that you can get your life
back i wrote this book so everyone could
read it not just science nerds like me
and my friends
and i priced it at 10 bucks so that
everyone can afford it this little book
landed on the best seller list and is
now being purchased by the case
and given away in counseling offices
universities churches and homes across
the country
i don't care if you're a teenager or an
executive or a 75 year old grandmother
this book is for everyone so go to
johndalone.com and get your copy of
redefining anxiety today
all right let's go out to fort myers
florida and talk to rebecca hey rebecca
what's going on
hey dr john how are you oh i'm just
peachy
that is the universal sign of universal
word of
kind of crappy i've never met somebody
who says i'm doing peachy and they
actually are doing great so
what's going on rebecca how's your world
oh my world is
very busy right now but that's okay um
so i am
calling because four years ago they
four years ago the day before mother's
day i lost my mom
oh my god how'd she pass away
um not of natural causes
okay yeah it was very
traumatic to our family because
you know um and so there's four of us
siblings and everything and
you know the three of us seem to deal
with it okay
but my one sister she's like
really dwelling on it and i i mean like
i understand like people grieve
different but i think
she's getting obsessive she's drinking
she's like
she's just being really obsessed about
it
and you know it's like i got into the
point where like i don't want to get
sucked into the drama of it
and you know it's like i'm trying to
figure out how to deal with her because
you know me and her
are the closer in age and we grew up and
we went through a lot together
yeah and it's like i don't want to
completely shut her out but i'm at the
point of like i want to
because i don't want to get sucked into
it absolutely especially when she
probably
said to me well you don't understand you
didn't lose your mom and i'm like
wait she had me one two three
four of us but okay i don't understand
wow
okay yeah so real quick when you
when you say she didn't die of natural
causes i mean did she take her own life
no okay um i mean to be i'm okay with it
so i could be frank because
it's just when i tell people they kind
of get really weirded out about it um
have
have you ever heard my show yes i listen
to you guys
religiously i would say yeah there's not
a lot of there's not a lot of weird left
so go ahead
so okay so my stepdad who who basically
raised me and
well um me and my sister that's our
stepdad and then
our brother and sister that's their dad
he has schizophrenia
and so after 20 some years he had an
episode and he ended up stabbing my mom
to death
and then calling the police saying that
he murdered his wife
okay and so yeah so no and when i saved
natural causes
i mean yeah no gotcha okay so this was
a a exclamation point trauma
right this isn't a trauma like somebody
passed away from cancer this isn't
somebody took their own life this is
something that was a
violent yeah horrific evil okay
um and so you said you and the other
other two of you is it brothers and
sisters all sisters
yeah i have one brother and i have two
sisters okay so
one of your your brother and one of your
sisters y'all have
dealt with it okay when anyone says i've
dealt with it okay i call bullcrap but
tell me what that means what does i've
dealt with it okay mean
well like okay so my brother and my
sister that's their dad
right and all that and you know i mean
we kind of like
knew okay like he was sick and stuff
but i mean like we always like knew when
an episode was going to happen because
but he never hurt us or my mom or
anybody he always like try to take his
own life
so when this happened this way it was a
big shocker to all of us
so but it's like okay you know
we're just i guess we're at peace with
it but her she is not at peace with
it when you say you're at peace with it
what does that mean
like i know i know where my mom is like
and you know i know i
one day i'll see her you know i probably
cried maybe
three times over it i did grief sharing
and i did not care for the grief sharing
because once she gets in my story
everybody wants to hang on it because
you know every day you meet somebody
that in that situation usually people
die of sicknesses or something like that
it's sensational yeah yeah um and i
didn't want to be sensational
okay so when you say this is four years
ago so you
you were able to tell me about it and
you you
like laughed a little bit before so
you're able to talk about it without
um your eyes welling up anymore um
you're able to have that conversation
it's not fun or pleasant it's never
something you're like hey guess what but
you're able to do that right
yeah okay um
but for uh and i know you know the
answer to this i'm just i'm gonna ask
you this question for the
just the average listener all
you can four years later quote unquote
be on a healing path right um
but you still miss your mom right oh of
course
like i miss every day i mean like before
it all happened i talked to her
every day on the phone that's right you
know because my husband's a truck driver
so i talked to him on the phone then i
talked to her on the
it phone like a routine i i want people
listening to know healing doesn't mean
you just don't think about it anymore
and you're all good
healing means you can breathe right you
can laugh again you can go to somebody's
birthday party again you can actually
open a christmas present again or
experience mother's day again
right um yeah without hyperventilate
right without your body taken over so
okay so when you say your sister can't
she can't
process it she can't deal with it what
does that mean she's drinking a lot what
else um
well like uh last year around fourth of
july
she because you know she's my husband
um has some issues in the past so you
know he's a recovered addict been clean
for eight years
um and all that stuff so she's like well
let me talk to him
well at the time we were all dealing
with kovid and you know he's sleeping
sick as a dog
and i'm like well he's sleeping sick and
he's like well you she goes well you
don't understand i need to talk to him
and i'm like
yeah so um then she has sent me a
picture with a cord wrapper on her neck
and she lives in new york i live in
florida
so i had to call the police department
up there and be like hey yeah
good for you good for you rebecca so i
did that
and all that and then um you know but
then like i got
kind of bullied by her friends well
you're not here
you're you're not being compassionate
and it's like well i live in florida she
lives in new york
i i mean i'm as compassionate and as
fair as i possibly can
you know and you know you know
my husband and i were talking about he
thinks because i have my kids and my
family my brother has his job and
everything my other sister has her kids
but
my sister doesn't have anything like we
do and that's probably why
she's dwelling on it so
answering one thing here her friends
don't get a vote on how you run your
life
okay they don't get to tell you the
right way to talk to your sister deal
with your sister et cetera that's your
sister
and they may know her better than you by
now they may interact with her every day
they don't get to they don't get a vote
right if you're gonna call the police
good for you i'm proud of you i know
there's a hard phone call good for you
the second thing is is i think there may
be some merit to what your husband's
saying
um a key component of healing from grief
over time
is relationships with other people
especially relationships where you can
show up
and have your good days and have your
really really dark days
and you know you're still loved and you
know that someone
is gonna expect you to be there
if someone's gonna expect you to wake up
someone's gonna
show up when you can't get out of bed
right that's part of the healing process
and yes there is something about
isolation
here's the thing i don't really care
the why here okay the reality of this
situation is some people don't come back
from trauma like this
and i say don't come back some people
cannot
say goodbye to their mom when they die
some people can not let go
of that feeling because if they let go
of the feeling then mom's finally gone
dad's finally out of here and
it's a really tall ask for some folks
and so at the end of the day
four years later is it wrong that she
still thinks to mom and gets her heart
broken and cries
no absolutely not everybody does that
differently right
um but if she is putting
her burden on you right then at some
point you got to let her know i love you
more than life itself i'm your sister
i'll always be there for you you can
call me at any time
i'm not going to talk about this anymore
yeah and that's just about you
establishing your boundaries and so what
i would love for you and your husband to
do is to
come up with hey what are husband what's
your husband's name
his name is randy hey randy when i talk
to sister
and i just hang up the phone and i'm
devastated or i'm all spun
up or i just come to you and i'm like
hey i need a couple of tall boys to make
my day better right
whatever whatever you happen to be ask
him what are the things that she's told
me or you may know what are the things
that really spin you up and that's what
you have a direct conversation with her
and say hey
you grieve how you need to grieve i love
you
we're not talking about i'm not talking
about this with you anymore you talk
about it with a counselor with a pastor
with a therapist
with your friends i am not going to
continue to entertain xyz
yeah right and that's not you loving her
any less in fact
often when people are spiraling and
they're hurting having boundaries
becomes a great great gift
and if she does haul off and hurt
herself that's not your fault
yeah you know what i mean yeah
are you the oldest i am i'm the oldest
out of all of us
and so let me give you another how how
much older are you
than her how far y'all i am three years
older than her
okay um sometimes there's this
it's a nerdy psych word called
transference in some ways you might
become mom for her now
and she needs your approval she needs
you to listen she needs to
whine and complain to you the same way
you used to do to your mother
and more importantly
if she has transferred mom to you
there's a part of her brain that says at
any moment you're gonna go next
and so every conversation becomes about
how can i
grab on to you how can i hold tightly
onto you
almost to the point that it strangles
you right or that you're like a little
kid gets around your legs and you can't
walk it kind of feels like that right
yeah and so that's just you just like
any
good older sister any sibling any friend
any mom any dad
you got to develop your boundaries and
then she's going to have the healing
work if she wants to do it
i do think a in this situation
i've seen it over and over uh writing
her a letter that she can hold in her
hand you've heard me say that a million
times
writing her a letter she can hold in her
hand and read and let her know i love
you
and i think it's time for all of us to
let mom go
and then if she calls you back and says
you don't understand it's not this
then you've done what you can do there
and then you're going to draw these
boundaries i'm not going to talk about
this anymore
yeah is that something you can do
oh yeah i can do that awesome and if
she's willing to
have her call the show i'm i'd love to
talk to her too
oh she loves you guys so i'll probably
convince her
yeah have her have her call and she can
say i'm the sister my older sister's the
worst
rebecca and florida's terrible right she
wouldn't do that but
um yeah at the end of the day how she
grieves is how she grieves
there is a point i always am really
hesitant to say someone should be over
something by now
because that means something it means
something different to
so many people what does over it mean
that you're not crying
man you can be dead on the inside or not
crying you can be completely out of
tears
or you can cry every day and be totally
functional you just miss somebody
and some people cry when they miss
people and some people laugh when they
miss people and some people are just
annoying to be around they miss people
it's different for everybody so i'm
never going to say
you got to be over it by now we got to
get up and get going like you got to be
i'm not going to say that but
there is a moment when you have to
whether it's a process whether it's a um
funeral a second funeral hey hey i wanna
get all the brothers and sisters back
like we've had four years to think
through this i want us to all like we're
gonna we're gonna let mom go
like we've been all struggling with this
dealing with this in our own little ways
we're gonna let mom go whatever that
looks like for you
having some sort of moment and then you
gotta be around people
who are going to witness your grief and
then help you
move on help not move on but help you
come to terms with your new life
right so yeah reach out to her tell her
you love her
write her a letter and then draw some
boundaries we're not gonna talk about
mom anymore
or we're gonna talk about mom in this
way not in that way i'm not gonna talk
about your alco i've
told you this to um we'd help you with
recovery i told you we'd help you with
mental health challenges i told you we'd
do those things you're choosing not to
and that's okay
but i'm not gonna be part of it anymore
right thank you so much for that
callback i know that's hard and i know
it's messy and i know everybody does
grief differently
um at this point you've got to make sure
you and your husband are well
right you and your husband your kid so
thank you so much for that call all
right let's go to monica
in richmond indiana what's up monica
hey john how's it going outstanding how
about you
i'm all right i'm all right
let's let's do this what's up okay so
i'm having issues getting my husband to
open up to me
he's got some mental health issues
a lot of quote unquote demons
that he's trying to work through okay
and
i know there's something troubling him
but he's just not
wanting to open up and talk to me cool
thanks for sharing that so
um how long have you all been married
it'll be two years
in august okay but we've been together
for five okay
and when you say mental health issues or
challenges what
tell me what you're talking about he's
got some adhd
um he's got anxiety and
bipolar depression okay um
what's bipolar depression where
he will his his days are really good
but then his bad days are bad but he's
not diagnosed bipolar
bipolar no okay the depression
has good days and then really bad days
okay what's a really bad day look like
where um he gets he just clams up
he uses his phone like social media
as a coping mechanism where he will just
scroll
and not talk to anybody not want to do
anything
not want to get up from the bed or the
couch
he just stares at his phone just goes in
the hole huh
yes and what what set this off
um it varies all the time it can be
something minor like hey when i
ask him you know take off the track or
can you take out the trash
and um other times
it's his job sometimes it's a
conversation with one of his family
members
it's just all over the place
was he doing this before y'all were
married it wasn't as bad
um it just it's gotten
so much worse over the last five years
and you don't know has he been doing
this his whole life or this
last five years or six years the
diagnosis
came well he's had adhd since i've ever
known him
yeah and we went to high school together
and
but the anxiety and depression have been
diagnosed over the last
i'd say three to four years okay
[Music]
so two two tracks i want to take here
first track is talk to you
okay okay um
i can't think of a more devastating
loneliness
in loving somebody so much
and them hurting and they don't tell you
how or why they're hurting
and it's like you're standing over a
cave just saying hey we
grab my hand and they're saying no
right and at some point you toggle back
and forth between being really pissed
off
just grab my hand what are you doing and
then you also if you're like most normal
humans maybe not you
you spend a season i must be putting my
hand in wrong
right it's almost this um gaslighting
that's not
words but it's it's in a response to
actions like i must not be
it must be my fault if i just knew the
right way to reach down there and grab
them then i could help out
right and it feels so lonely is that
ring a bell at all
a little bit yes and i was like i know
there's something some way i can help
him
okay i'm a fixer yes but i know i
i can't fix everybody but i want to help
as much as i can
yeah poof okay
so this is especially fun for fixers
right
so the most important thing you can know
is that him
taught not talking to you him not
opening up with you him not
being transparent with you isn't about
you
and fixers really struggle with that
because in their mind everything is
about them and they can just solve
pretty much any problem if you'll just
let me see all the parts to it i'll put
the puzzle together i just need all the
pieces well
i've learned that i can't do that i've
i've learned to kind of tote it back but
i'm still it's it's still hard for me
well and here's the thing
your head knows that but your heart
doesn't right
and so what you are going to start doing
is you're going to start getting anxious
and you're going to start like anxiety
and depression are on the same trend
line
right i don't like them even as two
different diagnostics because they just
work together so closely
and so um you are going to begin
to find yourself if you haven't already
being super frustrated
and you start just scrolling or you just
start checking out
or you right you'll find yourself there
because there's a disconnect between
what you know in your head this isn't
about
me and your body is looking at this
person you love
completely shutting everybody else out
right and that begins to wear on your
soul right
so here's one or two things you can do
as a fixer that's not going to make you
feel good as a fixer
but it's the best you can get okay okay
and i want you to think of his life in
and i got this from emily nagaski from a
series of
ons and offs because people who have
deep anxiety people are struggling with
depression it's
a physical safety issue most of the time
so there is something in his head
something in his body that is saying
you are not safe right now you are not
something about his ecosystem is saying
you're out of control you don't know
what's coming next you're disconnected
and so what folks do is they pick up
their phone and stare at it right they
go have another drink and another drink
and another drink they go meet another
another um
lady another guy to make it like it ban
it you know band-aids over
this fear that they have that they're
not meeting up at home
right so all of a sudden
um this and then oh what does that do it
just compounds the disconnection and it
compounds that
that you're not safe and the internet
will tell you whatever you wanna what
whatever you wanna know so if you're
scared about something it will magnify
that fear right and it just goes on and
on and on right
so what are some ways you can create
as safe a home as possible at the same
time not becoming a doormat
so what you're looking to do is not fix
him
you're looking to create safety
create peace right and then
he may say that's uh i'm
uh i think i want to talk about this now
okay
so what does that look like sitting down
with him and saying hey you know what
i've been driving you crazy about this
whole thing
i know you're struggling i'm not gonna
bother you with anymore i trust that you
love me enough that when you're ready to
talk
um you know i'm here
and you know i'll go to the ends of the
earth for you
in the meantime what are some things
around here that i could do
to help make this a more peaceful home
for you to come to
what are some things around here i can
do to
um not tell you
not hassle you not fix you but
to let you feel that you're loved around
here
and monica this is critical
because this is the moment when people
become codependent they become doormats
and you've got to go do the work on you
what does that mean that means you have
to go
talk to a professional because you're
married to somebody
who is not doing well and
at some point they're choosing to not do
well right
because there is healing if you wanted
to go down that road and right now he's
not choosing that road
he's not choosing you but he's not
choosing to get well right
and you're still going to invite him to
the concert and he's just ignores you or
says i'm not going
that's when you say cool i'm taking
susan and we're going
because at some point you've got to
begin to do the things that make you
feel well
make you connected you choosing to
disconnect from your world
because he doesn't want you to ends up
making everybody sick it drowns the
whole house does that make sense
yes so go to church even if you won't go
go to the concert even if he doesn't
want to go be the change you want to see
in your home
right grab books and read about this
stuff
if he does go see a counselor ask hey
can i come with you and if he says
absolutely not say cool
i'm going to go to my appointment why do
you need to go to counseling you need to
go you're fine
well i live with someone who's
struggling and so i have to learn about
me
right that's when you are doing these
things you are making sure that you
are whole and well right
and then the next part of this whole
conversation is him and so this is me
talking to
anybody who feels like their only friend
is their cell phone
the only safe place is on a couch or
under your covers
please don't choose that life
and i am intentional about that language
i know there are days people cannot get
out of bed
they can look at someone who cares about
them and say help please
they can make that call even if it's an
online therapist they can make that
phone call
folks who are struggling and i've been
cr i've been crippled with anxiety
to where i could hardly move there was a
lot of lifestyle choices i could i ended
up having to make
there are relationships i had to reach
out to that were super uncomfortable
super awkward super weird there are
seasons when i've been in i didn't want
to get out of bed i didn't want to do
and you get up out of bed or you reach
out and you call someone say hey i'm
struggling getting up
i need some help right and so there is a
responsibility there
even when you think you can't do it
there is a responsibility
to open your eyes and say help me or put
both feet on the floor and take one step
and then take one more step if you're so
anxious and spun out
make that phone call and go see somebody
and say help please
please help and i want everyone
listening to know
there is light on the other side of that
tunnel there is
and it's often sometimes the avenue that
help is
sitting there right in your house like
monica here right
so monica if we had to step back and say
what is that the heightened point of
tension
what are the points that are just kind
of rattling your marriage right now
what would they be
well it's it's lack of communication is
a big one
um you know lack of help around the
house as well
um i'm i'm working two jobs now because
we're following the dave ramsey plan
and um you know i'll i'll put like
[Applause]
you know dogs need to be fed and
trash needs taken out on our dry erase
board at home
as like a hey these kind of need done um
could you help me out
kind of kind of that message i'm going
for and
um i'll put a little like
love you kisses type little sign off on
it
to let him know that i'm that i love him
and
um you know if i come home and he's
sitting on the couch
on his phone not paying attention to our
two-year-old i'll
kind of be like hey did did you at least
get anything done he's like
no yeah and then i
i get irritated i've been trying not to
you know
lash out at him or you know as soon as i
walk through the door
and i see him i've been trying not to be
like hey did you get all this done
i'm trying to work on myself and say
you know hey how was your day and then
walk those questions in
are you um
when's the last time you went on a date
it has been a hot minute when's the last
time y'all had
um or anything other than
her functory like duty
like intimate um
[Music]
well intimacy is a
few and far between it's
he he he also uses sex as a coping
mechanism
and so there's a lot of
you know taking on his part on that
but not a lot of giving for me
so i feel a little bit used in that area
so i don't really
monica not a little bit you feel a lot
used okay yeah okay
yeah right and then it starts the big
cycle because absolutely you're not a
jungle gym
and you're not his blankie and at the
same time
his his challenges are craving
connection
and he doesn't know how to do that
verbally he doesn't know how to do that
respectfully and that's the one
connective outlet he's got right
yes um so i'm gonna be as honest as i
can with you
um your marriage is in a lot of trouble
am i fair yes okay
um i think it's fair for him to know
that
because i know he feels that i know you
feel that it's full of your house
it feels like you are more his mom right
now than his wife you are more his
caretaker than his lover yes right
and absolutely that's a dangerous dance
to get into because it's really hard to
get out of that
right because nobody wants to hook up
with their mom and nobody
wants to be romantic with their son
right right and or
if that's a gross analogy for you nobody
not for you but for
the listener nobody wants to i don't
even go down that road so
y'all y'all are in a dangerous dance
it's a cycle and it goes
it'll spin faster and faster and faster
and it has been over the last five years
right
so at some point someone's got to turn
the lights on turn the music off and say
i'm done with this dance
because here's the thing most people
don't stop the dance because they're
worried about what's going to happen
and what i'm going to tell you is what's
going to happen is going to happen
anyway this marriage ends up in ashes
anyway and you just lose a lot of years
of your life
so somebody's got to flip the lights on
say whoa
what's going on here
i need everybody to go get into a
marriage counselor's office tomorrow
right i'm not going to live in a
desire-free marriage any longer i
deserve more than that
you deserve more than that i'm not going
to watch the man that i love
just wilt away in the floor of our
living room with a cell phone
i'm not a girl or boy little boy little
girl
little boy little boy i'm not gonna let
my son grow up thinking that this is
what
partnership looks like that this is what
marriage looks like that this is what
fatherhood looks like i refuse
right right how close are you to
calling it i have been
within a hair's length
before and it's we'll have our
our good good days and then something
bad will trigger it
and you know he'll make me mad and
i'll just start thinking of you know
all the past stuff that he's done how
it's all piled up
and then i'll be like okay well next
time it's the last time that i'm doing
this
i'm done and then he'll be really sweet
and it'll be like
we're fine we're perfectly fine until
the cycle starts starts again
monica you are you are teetering over
the edge of resentment and you know what
i think about resentment
yes you're real real close
i have i have been on the edge of
resentment with him before
oh it was so hard to come back from that
so listen here's where you're at
choose the right time the right moment
do not do it in a fight
do not do it on the heels of a
disagreement or when he forgot to take
out the trash or
that's when he chose not to take out the
trash right
right set it up a moment set up a
breakfast set up a lunch
get some child care and say hey we've
got to have this conversation now
i'm worth this you're worth this we are
worth this
our baby's worth this
everybody involves life is worth more
than what y'all are
giving it right you need to be married
to somebody who cherishes the ground you
walk on who desires you who goes to war
for you who laughs with you who you
don't have to write chores on a
whiteboard for
right and he deserves to have a wife
that is all
in that can't wait to get home
man man man
if you're out there i'm looking at you
if you are out there and you're
struggling anxiety you're struggling
with depression
call somebody today do not drown
on your own don't don't you can make the
call
you may not be able to get out of bed
you can make that call
if you were somebody whose cell phone is
more important to you than your wife
put it away if you're somebody whose
cell phone is more important than your
kids
throw it off your roof
throw it off your roof your kids aren't
worth your cell phone your husband's not
worth your cell phone
they're not
if you are teetering on the edge of
resentment stop the dance
if you are spinning out of control stop
the dance somebody turn off the music
somebody turn on the lights and say
i'm worth more than this you're worth
more than this let's
stop and figure this out
and if one of them says well screw you
i'm out of here listen they're out of
there anyway
they were out of there anyway
i hate that for you monica my heart's
broken for you turn the lights on man
turn off the music and let's have that
conversation
write me back let me know how that goes
and we'll let the listeners know how
that conversation goes
it's gonna be a hard one and it may not
go great
you're gonna have to have an or what
plan if he says we'll screw you i'm not
doing anything you're gonna have to have
an or what plan
i know that you already have one
actually i know you do
hey what a perfect song to segue with
what a perfect song to segue with
to get us out of this hard moment
there's nothing like a band
who came out in the 2000s
and their whole mission was to reclaim
the chaos that was the 80s hair metal
2003
a cd a record came from the gods and it
was called permission to land
by a little band in london who nobody
wanted on their record label but who
kept selling out all these arenas
because people just wanted to jam they
were called the darkness
and the song is i believe in a thing
called love and it goes like this
can't explain all the feelings that
you're making me feel
my heart's in overdrive and you're
behind the steering wheel
i it's so bad you got to do that you got
to do the voice
touching you touching me
touching you you're touching me
i believe in a thing called love come on
do the voice
there's a chance we can make it now
we'll be rocking to the sun goes down
i believe in a thing called love
right here on the dr john deloney show
[Music]
you